u.s ambassador to the united nations
meets aid workers at the turkey border
with syria
and they tell her about what's described
as life-saving assistance they are
giving to people
in syria in a few weeks linda thomas
greenfield
will confront russian resistance to
renew the cross-border mechanism
on the grounds that it violates syria's
sovereignty
when i get back to new york i will be
briefing members of the security council
on what i've seen here and i will be
appealing to my colleagues
to support the continuation of this
operation
and to reopen the two other border
crossings that were closed
bevel hawa is the only entry point for
the un to bring aid into the opposition
held
northwest it's also the last of four
international crossing points
that have been closed because of russia
syria's ally
we need as much access as possible in
fact what we need at the moment is more
access not less we need to scale up the
response because
the aid that we're providing is simply
not enough
this is you know the biggest
displacement crisis of the 21st century
nearly 4 million people live in the
northwest many are internally displaced
by the conflict
80 percent rely on aid brought from
turkey
the u.n currently sends more than 1 000
trucks carrying aid
every month
the aid is not enough even for
one-fourth of the population
if the u.n can't use the border there'll
be a famine
local and international ngos cannot fill
the gap as
hunger and malnutrition grow aid workers
say the infrastructure set up in turkey
to run the operation
can't be easily replaced the u.n is the
largest actor in the humanitarian
response
the u.n gives more than 50 of all aid if
that stops
it's a death sentence for the people
russia wants u.n
operations re-routed through damascus
but human rights and aid groups warn
against this they accuse the syrian
government of using aid as a weapon
by keeping it from its opponents and
using it to benefit those
who are loyal for months now we have
seen behind the scenes negotiations
primarily between the united nations and
between damascus to try to achieve
one single cross-line delivery
from damascus to idlib and until now
those negotiations have led to nothing
the biden administration has been vocal
in its criticism of how damascus handles
aid deliveries
and now with the u.s envoys visit the
stage is set for what will likely be
an intense period of negotiations to
keep open the gates to syria's
opposition held areas senator al jazeera